good morning Hank it's Friday September
15th today I'm going to read a cut for
time version of the second half of the
first chapter of my new book Paper Towns
here's the thing I found a dead guy
little adorable 10 year old me and my
even littler and more adorable playdate
found a guy with blood pouring out of
his mouth and that blood was on her
little adorable sneakers as she biked
home and that's all very dramatic and
everything but so what I didn't know the
guy
people I don't know dial the damn time
if I had a nervous breakdown every time
something awful happened in the world
I'd be crazier than a rat that
night I went into my room at 9 o'clock
to go to bed because nine o'clock was my
bedtime my mom took me in told me she
loved me and said see you tomorrow
and I said see you tomorrow and then she
turned out the lights and closed the
door almost all the way as I turned on
my side I happened to see Margo Roth
Spiegelman standing outside my window
her face almost pressed against the
screen I got up and opened the window
but the screen stayed between us
pixellating her I did an investigation
she said quite seriously up close I
could tell that she had a little
notebook and a pencil with teeth marks
around the eraser she glanced down at
her notes mrs. Feldman from over on
Jefferson Court said his name was Robert
Morris she told me he lived on Jefferson
Road and one of those condominiums on
top of the grocery store so I went over
there and there were a bunch of
policemen and they asked if I worked my
school paper and I said that our school
didn't have a paper and then he said as
long as I wasn't a journalist he would
answer my questions
he said that Robert Morris was 36 and he
was a lawyer
they wouldn't let me in his apartment
though but a lady named Juanita Alvarez
lives next door to him and I got into
her apartment by asking if I could
borrow a cup of sugar from my mom and
then she said that Robert Morris had
killed himself with a gun and then I
said why and she told me that he was
getting a divorce and he was sad about
it lots of people get divorces and don't
kill themselves I said I know that's
what I was thinking so it can't be that
right I guess I said I just wanted her
to keep talking that small voice tents
with the excitement of almost knowing
things I think maybe I know why she said
I think maybe all the strings inside him
broke she said and then before I could
think of anything to say she reached up
on her tiptoes and whispered shut the
window so I did
I thought she would leave but she just
stood there watching me I waved at her
and smiled but her eyes seemed fixed on
something behind me something monstrous
that had already drained the blood from
her face and I felt too afraid to turn
around and see but there was nothing
behind me of course except maybe the
dead guy
I stopped waving and sat down on the
floor so that my head was as high as her
head and we just stared at each other
from opposite sides of the window I
don't remember how it ended if I went to
bed or she did in my memory it doesn't
end we just stay there looking at each
other forever
the next morning I took the screen out
of that window and hid it in the back of
my closet where it remains
I took an elective in poetry my
sophomore year because I heard that
Margo was taking it by then we weren't
friends really because she was already
the High Priestess of Winter Park High
School she was friendly to me but I
never had anything to say to her really
except occasionally during classes the
great surprise of that class was that I
actually liked poetry at least some of
it there's this one poem we read called
howl and it starts out I saw the best
minds of my generation destroyed by
madness starving hysterical naked I've
never seen Margo starving or hysterical
and God knows that I've never seen her
naked but somehow and this is why I like
poetry those words still describe her as
she stood outside my window her blink
less blue eyes starving and hysterical
and naked staring back at me I think she
was still trying to piece it together
how the strings break I mean as she
stared at me Margo always loved
mysteries and in everything that came
afterward I could never stop thinking
that maybe she loved mysteries so much
that she became one Hank I look forward
to hearing the rest of your first
chapter on Monday and then we returned
to the funny